Utah's crazy domain expansion and
surprise new copied curse technique
yuji's insane Soul shaking new powers
and The Inevitable Defeat of sukuna all
of that will be covered in this crazy
chapter so make sure to stay tuned for
that smash that like button if you enjoy
seeing ji Jutsu kaai and videos like
this one and want to keep them coming
make this the video you join the fan by
subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future JSU Kaizen reviews and updates
we're insanely close to hitting 2
million subscribers at this point I
can't believe I'm saying that we're
talking less than th000 Subs away from
that goal so who knows you may be the 2
millionth subscriber when you push that
subscribe button and now without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
last chapter included UTA finishing off
Kaku but not before Kaku made it so that
sukuna can activate the merger of
humankind with Tangen if things get bad
enough for sukuna that's always
something to watch out for now and as
we'll see things are getting a lot worse
for him than most people probably
expected and probably sooner than most
people expected we left off with Utah
activ activating his domain expansion
and I love to see special grade domain
expansions and Utah was thinking to
himself he'll finish everything within
this domain while Yuji is helping him
hoping to deliver a definitive blow that
can shake souls in order to tear
megumi's body from sukuna of course this
is shown in and it's not just about
defeating sukuna and killing him but
also about Yuji saving his friend megumi
as sukuna pointed out well last chapter
how nice everyone has a role and I'm
very happy with the way the mangaka is
handling this but more on that later on
so the Nar tells us with the beginning
of this chapter that the special grades
domain has been revealed talking of
course about uta's domain true and
authentic love allows UTA to select one
curse technique that he has copied and
can apply it as a sure hit to his domain
however here's a more interesting part
to me techniques other than that one are
held randomly inside the katanas inside
the domain and only UTA can use those
abilities UTA himself doesn't know what
curse technique is dwelling inside which
Katana until he holds it the katana
perishes when the curse technique is
used once but there's no limit to the
number of katas so fascinating stuff
here I love it we got a game of luck to
an extent which is always interesting to
see but we can also see some other
surprise techniques that Utah has copied
and in this chapter there's a big
surprise coming to be sure sukuna did
not see that one coming but more on that
in a bit so we have sukuna the king of
curses here we have ra the queen of
curses we have UTA of course Yuji as
well sukuna is thinking about how his
total cursed energy is currently on the
same level as uta's sukuna at this point
can't use domain expansion and his
reverse technique is slow due to the
fight with Gojo which is not helping him
during this fight and I really like that
detail after sukuna achieved his true
many armed form after he defeated goo it
seemed like he might be stronger than
ever but it's nice to know that yeah
goo's effort did have a lasting effect
on him and is helping the team right now
and now if our guys pull it off you can
say that goo helped make it possible his
sacrifice wasn't in vain it's an easier
pill to swallow Yuji and Utah working
together to defeat a Gojo drain sukuna
especially since part of the strategy is
for Yuji to use his unorthodox Soul
shaking abilities after Gojo Was
Defeated I was like how can they
possibly beat him now in a realistic way
but the mangaka is definitely doing a
good job by coming up with a way to
defeat him where everyone plays a part
and it's not just about overpowering
sukuna with strength this whole chapter
is mostly fighting and I'm not
complaining because that's what we all
like to see so as I've been talking
about we get Yuji attacking the border
of sukuna and fushiguro souls in this
way he's attempting to awaken fushiguro
from his Slumber and disrupt the sink
between fushi guro's physical body and
sua's soul again props ataka for coming
up with a creative way of fighting
sukuna post goo I'm loving it we're told
the more yuji's hits connect sukuna
cursed energy decreases and his control
of curse technique also decreases and
soon he will be unable to maintain his
current form so believe it or not after
he dealt with Gojo he's now being pushed
into a corner it's not looking good for
sua I can't believe I'm saying that at
the same time SU is worried about his
cursed energy output falling to the
point where he can no longer maintain
Hollow wicker basket and then there's
the real risk as he calls it their
desire to use the Angel's technique
Jacob's Ladder to eradicate the cursed
object within fushiguro megumi UTA uses
to's technique as well he tells suguna
don't move and then takes advantage of
the Frozen sukuna by immediately
following up with an attack which sends
suguna flying and of course demolishing
some pillars in the process we also see
RA in this chapter breaking up into four
smaller Ras who then act like honing
missiles attacking sukuna a lot of
different attacks coming his way and
honestly he impressive sukuna can
survive all of them considering how
different they all are sukuna does
attack our guys and R with his slashes
but he says to deal a fatal blow he
needs to touch and cut them he says it's
not just that his curse technique is low
due to the battle with Gojo because
obviously that is a factor but also
Jutsu Tech has upgraded the defensive
capabilities of their Frontline Fighters
alongside Yuji learning reverse curse
technique uta's domain is limiting sure
hit effect only on sukuna it's nice that
the mangaka is making it clear that hey
although goo was a part of this but we
have to give credit where credits do and
Yuji has definitely improved and the
Yuji and UTA together are doing amazing
right now sukuna wonders if UTA was able
to do this from the beginning but
applauds him for using this highlevel
barrier technique sukuna asks what have
they been doing this past month and of
course Yuji replies hard work and
determination or effort and perseverance
you know that always pays off for Shen
protagonists while UT answerers Foul
Play or we cheated and then Yuji and UTA
together are like oh they clearly and
hilariously had different views on the
preparation and it goes to show how
different these characters are although
I love them both in their own way and
it's definitely fitting that UTA is here
as someone that Gojo said will be able
to match him one day still UTA knows how
lucky they are to have made it to this
point and he thinks that if Gojo had not
left any lasting after effects on sukuna
they would have been instantly killed
without having time for reverse curse
technique so again the mangaka is making
a clear that Gojo's death was not for
nothing he's continuing to play a part
in giving these guys a chance Yuji for
his part is scared to even think about
what will happen if they don't put an
end to this right here they continue
fighting and UTA uses future prediction
to anticipate sukuna attack and it's
awesome he quickly evades and then kicks
sukuna in the face we're told so far by
sua's count UTA has used five different
copied curse techniques Jacob's Ladder
uro spatial Distortion applying a non
voidable barrier on Ra's trajectory to's
cursed speech and Charles future
prediction and yet despite this
onslaught of awesome curse techniques
and an illustration of just how
overpowered UT's copy ability is we will
continue to see others including one
that is about to shock sukuna himself
sukuna even wonders if it might be
Gojo's Infinity but then thinks it
shouldn't be because it can only be
controlled with the help of six eyes and
I like this I like that even though Utah
can copy a lot of overpowered abilities
there are caveats like this that keep
him from being able to just literally
copy everything while they are fighting
UTA says if if it's a new curse
technique sukuna has never seen there's
still room to surprise him which of
course tells us that UTA has more curse
techniques at his disposal ones that we
can eagerly look forward to UTA uses
udo's curse technique to bend space and
pushes a sword through it sukuna catches
it annoyingly but then UTA uses sua's
own curse technique cleave on sukuna
himself sukuna says that's my dot dot
dot two exclamation marks and then we
see sua's face begin to get slashed as
he finally gets a taste of his own
medicine the chapter had plenty of back
and forth what sukuna delivering damage
too but it definitely looks like our
team has the edge right now and we can
actually see a path to Victory
especially with yuji's soul shaking
abilities but you can never jump to
conclusions with a series that can go
from Gojo winning one chapter to him
dying the next chapter also we know that
the merger will have to come up again at
some point so we'll see what happens and
how quickly but I'm glad that I'm still
really enjoying this fight even without
Gojo let me know what you think will
happen next in the comments comments
below do you think that the writing is
on the wall that sua will fall sooner
than later or do you think that like up
until now we still have plenty of twists
and turns in store before it's all over
either way I think that they will defeat
him during this fight otherwise if sukna
has time to heal and all goo sacrifice
and impact will be severely lessened and
since everyone loves Gojo that would not
be so good to see but we'll just have to
trust in the mangaka for now and if you
enjoyed watching special great Utah at
work and it was awesome this chapter you
won't want to miss my all special grade
Sorcerers and their powers explained
video link on screen right now like And
subscribe to help us reach that insane
goal of 2 million subscribers we are
less than 1,000 subscribers away at this
point so you could be that 2 million
subscriber thank you so much and I'll
see you in the next one